well I have to ask about education here
this is a
this has been a stressful time for high
school teachers
teachers in general how do you think
large language models even at their
current state are going to change
education
first of all education is the way out of
poverty education is the way to success
education is what let my parents Escape
you know islands and sort of let their
kids come to MIT
and this is a basic human right like we
should basically get extraordinarily
better at identifying Talent across the
world and give that Talent opportunities
so we need to nurture the nature we need
to nurture the talent across the world
and there's so many incredibly talented
kids who are just sitting in
underprivileged places in you know
Africa in Latin America and the middle
of America in Asia and all over the
world we need to give these kids a
chance
AI might be a way to do that by sort of
democratizing Education by giving
extraordinarily good teachers who are
malleable who are adaptable to every
kid's specific needs who are able to
give the incredibly talented kid
something that they struggle with rather
than education for all we teach to the
top and we let the bottom behind or we
teach to the bottom and we let the top
you know drift off
have
you know education be tuned to the
unique talent of each person some people
might be credibly talented at math or in
physics others in poetry in literature
in art in you know Sports in you know
you name it
so
I think AI can be transformative for the
human race if we basically allow
education to sort of be pervasively
altered
I also think that humans thrive on
diversity basically saying oh you're
extraordinarily good at math we don't
need to teach math to you we're just
going to teach you history now I think
that's silly no you're extraordinarily
good at math let's make you even better
at math because we're not all going to
be growing our own chicken and hunting
our own figs or whatever they do
we're uh you know the reason why we're
Society is because some people are
better at some things and they're they
have natural inclinations to something
some things fulfill them some things
they're very good at sometimes they both
align and they're very good at the
things that fulfill them we should just
like push them to the limits of human
capability for those
and
um you know some people excel in math
just like
challenge them I think every every child
should have the right to be challenged
and if we
you know if we say oh you're very good
already so we're not going to bother
with you we're taking away that
fundamental right to be challenged
because if a kid this is not challenged
that's cool they're gonna hate school
and they're gonna be like doodling
rather than sort of pushing themselves
so that's sort of the educational
component the other impact that AI can
have is maybe we don't need everyone to
be an extraordinarily good programmer
maybe we need better General thinkers
and the push that we've had towards
these sort of very strict IQ based you
know uh tests that basically test you
know only quantitative skills and
programming skills and math skills and
physics skills maybe we don't need those
anymore maybe AI will be very good at
those maybe what we should be training
is General thinkers
and yes you know like you know I put my
kids through Russian math why do I do
that because you're teaching them how to
think and that's what I tell my kids I'm
like you know AI can compute for you you
don't need that but what you need is
learn how to think and that's why you're
here and
I think challenging students with more
complex problems with more
multi-dimensional problems with more
logical problems I think is
sort of perhaps a very fine direction
that education can go towards
with the understanding that a lot of the
traditionally you know scientific
uh disciplines perhaps will be more
easily solved by Ai and sort of thinking
about bringing up our kids to be
productive to be contributing to society
rather than to only have a job because
we prohibited AI from having those jobs
I think is the the way to the Future and
if you sort of focus on overall
productivity
then let the AIS come in let everybody
become more productive what I told my
students is you're not going to be
replaced by AI
but you're going to be replaced by
people who use AI
in your job so embrace it use it as your
partner and work with it rather than
sort of forbid it because I think the
productivity gains will actually lead to
a better society and that's something
that humans have been traditionally very
bad at every productivity gain has led
to more inequality
and I'm hoping that we can do we can do
better this time that basically right
now
a democratization of these types of
productivity gains will hopefully come
with
better sort of humanity level
um improvements in in human condition